for the first time both astronaut Nick
Hague and his wife for sharing dramatic
details about a failed rocket launch in
October Hague was in a Soyuz rocket
headed for the International Space
Station when a violent booster failure
forced him and caught and a cosmonaut to
abort the mission mid-flight more than
30 miles above Earth he and cosmonaut
Alexei ovchinin landed safely NASA
announced this week that Hague will fly
into space again
mark Strassmann is at the Johnson Space
Center in Houston with the interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning mark
good morning good morning I'm standing
inside building nine essentially the
training facility here for astronauts
and I want to show you something this is
a mock-up of a Soyuz capsule believe it
or not three people can squeeze inside
here Nick Hague trained in it training
that was critical when his October
launch went into crisis that moment was
a reminder that space exploration is a
family business and there is liftoff of
the soyuz ms 10 it was going perfect for
the first two minutes and then all of a
sudden there was this violent shaking
side-to-side and the alarms going off
and i see a red light that's lit up and
it says that you've had an emergency
with the booster Nick Hague now sees
last October's launch as a success
wrapped inside a failure 31 miles up a
faulty sensor had cost him his mission
but he was alive you were supposed to go
out for six months you were back on
earth in 20 minutes yeah what was that
like looking out the window and seeing
space and seeing the curve of the earth
and just the split second of just utter
disappointment about it's not going to
happen and we're coming home his shot at
space was also the dream of Katy Haig
his wife and their two young sons and at
some point the announcer stopped
announcing and the screens went green
and there was nothing you know something
had gone wrong I know something had gone
wrong did you fear the worst no no I
didn't I think I honestly mentally shut
that out in 18 years of marriage they
never had a moment like this what struck
me is how long about hug lasted yes and
I'm pretty sure I said something along
the lines of this might be a cause for
divorce
and please don't ever do that to me
again I just didn't want to let him go
you realize in that moment hey this
could have been really bad and I am so
lucky and thankful and happy to be
standing here holding you at the time
Haig admits worrying he might have lost
his one chance at space turns out one of
his sons had the same thought at some
moment he said well he tried it didn't
work out it's time to get a new job in
February NASA will give him a second
chance at the space station and that's
where this photo was taken
capturing the moment Haig reached the
edge of space before landing hard in a
life lesson what goes through your mind
when you look at that foot up life
doesn't always work out the way you plan
and more often than not what defines you
is how you bounce back from that behind
me there that's a mock-up of the
International Space Station
we're Nick Hague host who spends six
months doing scientific experiments
katie hague told us yes of course next
february before the launch she's going
to be nervous but they both believe in
two things nora his mission and that
next time the million little things that
have to go right will go right
that's absolutely the way to look at it
mark thank you and one of the best hugs
ever and we could say I'll bet they
learned something from what didn't go
wrong what didn't go right that they
will fix this next time but go Katie
Hayek's she's supporting him saying okay
he's ready to go well done yeah well
done is right